ازيكم عاملين ايه انا مبسوط ان انا معكم
كلكم انا مش شايف غير اول صفين من النور
بس انا وانا داخل كان في ناس كتير حاجه
خضتني بس اتمنى يبقى يوم لذيذ طيب
بتاعنا كنا بتكلم مع الناس هنا عايزين
نتكلم اكثر للناس الطلاب اللي بيتخرجوا
المدرسه ولسه عايزين يعرفوا يعملوا ايه في
الميجر يارب بصفتي خبير ومتخرج بقى لي
سنتين اللي اديهم
بتاع الموضوع
بس لو هنتكلم على المدارس انا واحد من
الناس لما كنت اول ما خرجت انا دلوقتي
متخرج من الجامعه بقى لي سنتين او تلاته
ثلاثه او اتنين اتنين ونص
اول ما اتخرجت من المدرسه كان عندي
يعني كان عندي مشكله كبيره قوي ان انا مش
عارف انا هختار في الجامعه عشان طبيعي ان
انا اخشه ده اللي انا هدرسه وده اللي انا
هشتغله فانت بتطلب من واحد عنده 18 سنه
ولا 17 سنه انه ياخد قرار هيعيش به بقيه
حياته
فلو جينا فكرنا مع بعض كده يعني وعلى طول
هاوجه كلامي للناس اللي بتتخرج من الفئه
العمريه دي
دلوقتي انا خرج مدرسه
جامعه خرج من جامعه
اشتغل
مع شهاده
لو مش معي الشهاده دي مش هشتغل
طيب لو قلت لك ان انا
ناس معايا في الشغل نفس السن واحد كان
بيشتغل في جوجل دخلت اعمل الشغل عندهم
السي او بتاع جوجل اللي هو تحت السي او
على طول في 2013 قال ان من كل عشره شغالين
عندنا في الشركه في جوجل كليتين في عشره
في واحد او اثنين ما دخلوش جامعه
شهاده جماعيه
ده جوجل
دي امريكا احنا بنتكلم على شركاتنا الحلوه
اللي في مصر اكيد عايزين
دي حقيقه هم فعلا اكيد عايزين شهاده في
امريكا برضو
30% من الناس اللي بتخرجوا من
مجال
بيشتغلوا فيه 70% بيشتغلوا في مجال تاني
طبعا احنا في مصر ما عندناش ارقام زي دي
بس كنت لسه انا في
الجامعه كنت بتكلم على البروفيسور الماسك
انا مهندس ميكانيكا
كريم احنا اخر ثلاث سنين من ساعه ما انت
اتخرجت والسنه اللي قبليك واني اخر ثلاث
سنين العدد اللي بيشتغلوا من اللي
بيتخرجوا عندنا بيشتغلوا في شركات ملهاش
علاقه بالهندسه بيزيد بطريقه مرعبه ووصل
العالميه اللي هو فوق
خمسه او سته مننا اشتغلوا في حاجه ملهاش
اي علاقه بالهندسه
طيب اللي انا عايز اقوله ايه انا عايز
اقوله ان انا نفسي اقول لنفسي وانا في
المدرسه وانا بختار ونفسي اقول لحد هنا
وهو بيختار بتاعه ان الميجل بتاعك اللي
هتختاره في الجامعه مهم
بس مش هو ده اللي هيحدد لك التاريخ بتاعك
لان في امثال في الواقع اشتغلت في حاجات
ما لهاش اي علاقه بالمتجر بتاعها
انا ميزان منهم انا واحد بشتغل في بيزنس
حاجه عليه علاقه بالبيزنس واصلا لما
اتقبلت انا كان معي خمسه تانيين كنا سته
دخلنا الشركه مع بعض شركه من اكبر شركات
في العالم يعني حاجه انت داخل بيزنس خمسه
مننا ما درسوش
طب ايه اللي بيفرق بالنسبه لي اللي بيفرق
بتاعك انا يعني عايز اقول لكم قصه برضو
انا لما وانا بختار بتاعي بعد اول سنه ما
كنتش عارف انا ايه كنت هندسه عشان معي
مجموع كبير فلازم اخش هندسه وانا جايب
مجموع هندسه فدخلت هندسه
فمش عارف اختار ايه وكان بقى لي سنه فمسكت
التليفون وقلت اكلم بابا واحد صاحبي عنده
شركه مقاولات كبيره قوي من انجح الناس
يعني في مجاله في مصر فكلمته
زي حضرتك انا اسف بس انا مش عارف انا هاخد
الموضوع صعب وده قرار بقيه حياتي كلها انا
فعلا عايز اجابه انا متعود في حياتي في
اجابات في الامتحان في اجابه في صح وفي
غلط مش متعود ان الموبايل يبقى الموضوع
مفتوح وان انا اللي بختار ولو مش عاجبك
البس انت هو قال لي حاجه هي اللي خلتني
اختار مكانك اللي على طول
قال لي بص يا ابني انت لو دخلت
هتطلع بتحديده اسمنت هتشتغل في العمارات
اشتغلت
ممكن تشتغل باور تشتغل الارقام تشتغل
ديزاين تشتغل بكترونيكس في امثله كتيره
قوي
انا عشان انا خايف اكيد ارتحت جدا لفكره
الاوبشن اهو انا مش عايز احط ضهر الحيطه
لا يعني انا عايز البيبان كلها تفضل
مفتوحه دخلت
بعد كده ان انا فكره دي اكبر بكثير قوي من
فكره هي في الحياه عموما يعني مش اوبشنز
ده عشان اعرف اشتغل منه شحنات اكتر لا انا
ممكن اخش اي متر واشتغل اي شغلانه
فهي مش فكره فكره انت ممكن تاخد ده ممكن
واحد يشتغل في بنكين ممكن واحد ثاني يشتغل
ممثل يبقى احسن ممثل واحد لعيب كوره واحد
انفلونسر واحد واحد كل واحد بس لازم تكون
عارف جواك ان لو شلت اي واحد من دول ناجح
حطيته كان ينجح فيه
فليه علاقه باللي انت بتعمله جوه
قبل ما اكمل كنت عايز اقولها في الاول هو
يعني انا عن نفسي لما بحب اخد معلومه من
حد كمان
ما بحبش او بفرق ما بين اللي انا خايف
عليا السيركل بتاعتي اهلي اخواتي صحابي
قريبين
هم خايفين علي في النصيحه لما بتدوها لي
بيوجهوني في الميجر وفي الطريق بتاعه في
الكارير بتاعي وبين ان هم عارفين الصح
على طول بفلتر ما بين ان هو انت خايف عليا
وانا عارف انت من جواك عايز الخير ليا
وبين ان انت فعلا عندك
انك تقدر تنصحني اللي هو رحت في الطريق ده
لان على طول اهلنا على طول مش لازم ياجونا
في طريق الصح
بس وجهولنا في الطريق اللي هم شايفينه صح
واللي هم خايفين علينا والطريق الامن
بالنسبه لهم
زي بالظبط اقرا كتاب انا باجي اقرا كتاب
انا بقرا كتاب اهو عشان يزود لي من
الافكار بتاعتي بتاعتي باخد الفكره اللي
فيه جوه ابني الافكار انا شايفها حلوه
شايفها صح انا شايفها مناسبه اللي داخله
دماغي وبلد عليها جوه
سهله قوي ان احنا يبقى عندنا كتاب مثلا
تطرف مثلا ديني واحد يقراه يبقى متطرف
واحد يقراه يبقى دعايه يحارب الفكره بقى
والاثنين قرروا نفس الكتاب
نرجع نتكلم فيها
حاجه تانيه برضو كنت اتمنى ان انا اقولها
او ان انا اكون مركز فيها صغير هو
التايمنج او البانس اللي هنعمله في حياتنا
مش عايز اقول بقى ان احنا في عصر السوشيال
ميديا وان انت انستجرام
والكلام ده كله
اللي عايز اقوله ان انت غصب عنك هتقارن
نفسك بالناس اوتوماتيك لي
وانا بقارن نفسي بالناس اوتوماتيك او يعني
اظن ان كلنا بنعمل كده ده اللي انا مقتنع
بيه بس انا
غصب عني وانا بقارن نفسي بالناس قررت ان
انا اعمل حاجتين
وفرقوا معي جدا بان المقارنه دي تبقى
هيلفي
اول واحده خلينا اول واحده بس ثانيه اول
واحده ان انا بحاول اقارن نفسي بالناس في
البث اللي انا انت فيه اللي انا حاطط نفسي
فيه يعني ما ينفعش ابقى انا شغال في
معين انا عايز ابقى لعيب كوره
ومركز قوي وبستثمر وقتي وحياتيك واجي ابص
على واحد تاني ايه ده بص ده قدي ده اشتغل
في مالطين عشان ونجح وصل وانا لسه ما
وصلتش
انا لو اقارن نفسي بحد اقارن نفسي بتاعي
انا عايز الموضوع بتاعي يبقى
تاني حاجه بقى هي المهمه ان انا بقارن
افيت مش بقارن
يعني ما ينفعش انا اخش الجيم اشوف واحد
فورمه
ايه ده ايه ده يا عم ده جاي همتنا ايه
الجسم ده انا مش عارف اتمرن جنبه ازاي عمل
كده ابتدي من جوايا حاسس ان انا قليل جنبه
بغار نفسي بالقفل الراجل ده بيتمرن عشر
سنين انا ان شاء الله
كيس على كده اي نجاح
واحد نجاح في غناء واحد نجاح في دراسه
واحد نجاح في واحد واحد
اتكلم مع الراجل ده
اخر حاجه يعني ان انا بالنسبه لي برضو
مهمه
اللي بحاول اديك حاجه او اديك حاجه وانت
بتختاري حاجه زي كذا في حياتك اللي ممكن
تتكلم وتساعدك
هو
انت عايز ايه هو انت داخل البعث ده دخل
الوليه عشان في هدف في حاجه انا في اخر
الطريق ده انا ده ده بيحركني لها انا عايز
اخد المعين ده عشان خلاص ده بتاعي لازم
تبقى تدفعني بتاعك في مشكله بقى صغيره بما
ان احنا نقعد خرجنا المدرسه زي ما قلت لكم
ما فيش اجابات فدي ملهاش اجابه انا اعرف
ازاي انا كويس في ايه واعرف ازاي انا بحب
ايه واعرف ازاي انا هنجح في ايه
ما انا لو عارف
كان زمان وصلت
صح
الحاجه اللي انا عايز اقولها ان بتاعك ده
هيتغير مع الوقت مش مهم يكون هو ايه المهم
ان انت تبقى اللي انت شايفه قدامك ده
اشتغل عادي دلوقتي اجري وراه وكل ما يتغير
كل ما بتتطور كل ما تبقى اكتر مش هنتغير
عادي اشتغل عليه غير بتاع لحد ما وصلت
لمرحله خلاص ده اللي انا عايزه ده اللي
انا هروح وراه ميه في الميه قبل ما اسيبكم
اقول حاجتين سرعه جدا
او ممكن حاجه عشان ما فيش وقت انا بحب قوي
لما اروح اخش في حاجه ما يبقاش وده اللي
انا عملته مثلا اول ما بدات اعمل فيديو في
الاول قبل ما بيزنس وصلت ما كان ابيض كنت
اول فيديو عملته ما كنتش عارف انا هقول
ايه بعد كده ولا كنت محضر ولا اي حاجه
حطيت الكاميرا زنقت نفسي رحت عامل فيديو
يا جماعه انا هعمل كذا وكذا وكذا وكذا رحت
منزل فيديو اول مره عملت بتاعي مكنتش حتى
عارف انا هنتج المصنع فين كنت واخد من
واحد صاحبي رحت طبعتها في مول رحت عامل
بيدج وانا قاعد في النادي في العربيه
حطيتها عملت وابتدى يجي لي اوردرز وانا
والله ما اعرف المصنع ولا عارف الفيشه
طبيعه وكام ولا اي حاجه بس انا بس بحط
ظهري في الحيطه
زنقت نفسي اعيش في اللي انت فيه ده كان في
حاجات تانيه كنت عايز اشير معكم بسكوتش
عارف ان انا اخد وقت كتير كده اتبسطت قوي
يا رب ما كنتش طولت عليكم
[تصفيق]